if it is in the royal monastery of yuste
in the spanish region of extremadura the
reason the award ceremony for the
carlos quinta european award this year
next to king felipe sixth of spain
was the president of the
european parliament martin schulz to pay
tribute to the laureate of  this tenth
edition the erasmus mom of experience of
the full immersion
james by life this former
university professor has spent more than 20 years
trying to convince rectors of
european universities to
recognize exchanges between
students before seeing the birth of
the erasmus program in 1987  that since then
has seen almost 4 million
young people travel the story of a European success
in a Europe today in crisis we have to
learn to live
together working together
that is the idea on which the
European project is based with this award
with which they have already  personalities
such as helmut kohl jack delhomme or
simon veil se  will finance 15
doctoral scholarships with the name of sophia
coradi and erasmus